[Music]
okay we heard you yeah no can you call
it because she won't let us pull it yeah
[Music]
oh my God what are you willing to get
[ __ ] naked lady all right guys
yeah dude
let's try to just stay calm and cool
okay
stop looking at him like it's her talk
to him he's trying to help you let me
get the number now what's this is
everything in my pocket
you want to Pat him down
that's all I got I'm still waiting for
the number well if it's if it's give
them the number you're a [ __ ] give him
the number give him the number that's
the only thing you have to do give him
if it's in his pocket it won't ring
because he turned off your ringer as
well you're also accusing myself even
though he just empty
emptied up here's his pocket with his
Vape in it you wanna do you want to turn
around guys can we she can't well if
they have my number then they and they
have my phone well let's
we don't have your phone I was I just
stuck it right here you walk right
behind it you type it in I did not take
it
you heard him laugh he went yeah cause
he knows he doesn't he knows he don't
have it he no he don't have it
you about to look stupid as [ __ ] you
about to look stupid
what are you doing
um really I am sorry no no now
I don't even want you sorry I don't want
to apologizing I don't want you to be
like I'm sorry I'm like you did all this
the number of times
the number of times the number of times
my girl looks for her keys and she's
looking for keys and I'm like have you
watched a purse and he's like yeah and
she looks in her purse and it's finally
there or I look in the person I'm like
yo that's your keys she don't go
accusing me of stealing her keys
Jesus and in your pockets oh my God can
you watch her you know when you know the
ending and you watch it back again you
notice like
she doesn't even look in the purse
properly my suspicion is she accused him
and then found the purse found on the
phone found the phone
it's kind of like Putin in Ukraine I was
like [ __ ] I can't back out now so we
gonna just bomb all these [ __ ] it's
the same idea because the number of
times the number of times yeah that he
asked just give me your number yeah
making up excuse you put it in yeah look
[Music]
yeah no can you
[Music]
stop looking in the
[Music]
could have turned off the ringer she's
making excuses not to make the call
because she knows it's gonna ring in her
purse that's what she's doing oh my God
naked lady all right guys shout out to
uh I think this dudes of the white woman
the white woman's like being hyper
aggressive about this
you wanted to get naked lady but that's
not a black woman that's it you think so
that's not a black one hold up what does
that voice that's not a black one I
promise that's something you want me to
Google it to confirm I'll put my money
on this one how much
I put I put a thousand I put a rack a
rack I put a whole rack on it you you're
gonna sell a rack I'll put a whole Rack
or you know exactly what the [ __ ] I've
been yeah okay okay right that's okay
let's go the woman at the end the woman
with the accused replies [ __ ] off
yeah that's why
but that's not a confirmation
white woman
you can see the lack of pigmentation
that's why are you gonna are you gonna
buy yourself a chinchilla coat with that
thousand dollars with a thousand dollars
hey man listen you have a good time
let's get back to the video
sidebar and it's not even important I
just no it's not all right
congratulations on your win T and Kinley
notice the woman looking at them
suspiciously she just turned the corner
and walked right up to him and I was
like I need to pull out my camera right
now because I know this is about to get
stupid really fast
I knew I didn't have it but she starts
feeling through the phone and the guys
it's like yo go call she doesn't she's
stalling for time no she doesn't wanna
bro bro you're you're you're your
hypothesis you think it's correct it's I
think it's a hundred she's calling it
yeah she's not looking because she's not
looking like someone that lost her phone
for real for real she's looking for
someone like ooh [ __ ] it's right there
the thing that makes her not want to
admit she's wrong is the same thing that
when women falsely accuse a dude or
people are false accused others and
they're set to get called out on their
lie they'll triple quadruple down on
their lot even though it makes no sense
in all the facts route yeah because they
don't want to have to admit they did
something that heinous yeah or that bad
yeah you know what I'm saying and so
she's trying to do that I apologize [ __ ]
off
no you're not
all right
no don't don't take your L and leave
take your Allen leave take your L and
leave you know what's interesting the
the most the guy started to laugh a song
even at the end he was just laughing you
want to know why because what else did
you want to do today's video is
sponsored by surf shark video is brought
to you by surfsharkvpn a VPN is an
application or an extension that you put
on top of your browser in order to
change or to mask your IP address you
know to change the location of your
computer why would you want to do that
well sometimes I want to listen to other
content from other country and they
won't let me in knock knock who's there
Canada won't let you win unless you're
from the UK switch the VPN changer and
then boom knock knock who's there
it's actually the UK now yes come in lad
come have some fee I know you guys don't
speak like that but you know what I mean
so you're able to watch much more
content and then boom the world is open
to you just like Aladdin on a carpet I
can show you the world and for the next
months you have 83 off in the three but
next month's free if you use Abba and
preach code a surf star VPN use the link
below go ahead you get used to seeing
that stuff so often and you're like you
don't even get angry like you used to no
the first couple of times you'll get mad
afterwards you'll be like
that [ __ ] again oh it's that [ __ ] oh is
that is that [ __ ] again yeah is that
[ __ ] again yeah cause you just don't
have the energy to get angry every time
you can't you can't you can't have a
reaction to everything that happening
you know I mean
it's embarrassing to be accused in that
way it's like it's such a hindrance you
have everyone staring at you like you
really did it because the moment someone
accused something everyone's looking
like oh there's something that really
did happen you know and it's just it's
one of those things you start rolling
your eyes like oh this is so [ __ ]
stupid this is such a waste of my time
and now you're embarrassing me and I was
like bro and I wouldn't want to sit
there talking about she's sorry she's
sorry it's like what made you accuse
someone so quickly so easily I don't
care you didn't even really properly
check your purse like it's not like you
dropped it somewhere in the store or
anything which would have normally made
it slightly less worse you didn't even
check your purse before you went to
accuse someone of theft that's crazy to
me that's crazy but it just shows you
the perception because I guarantee you
this right
if it was an old white dude standing
behind her she would have not assumed he
stole it she would have checked her
purse before she opened her mouth am I
lying do you guys really believe
children accused the old white dude of
robbing her purse no in her head she has
the perception of black people she had a
little issue and she immediately jumped
to that person as a culprit and you know
what this is a microcosm of what the
world does to black dudes all the time
be it fair or not I know I know because
I already know what it is when I'm
walking to certain places I understand
the way the world perceives me I get it
I already understand it so I'm moving
accordingly I have to be a little extra
this or a little extra that so that they
don't
me as an individual I know what I'm
about but it doesn't matter how I view
myself as an individual it doesn't
matter how you view people as
individuals none of that matters because
at the end of the day people coming to
snap judgments about other groups I'm
not even saying it's a good or a bad
thing it's not even to pass judgment I'm
just saying it's the reality of the
world
mm-hmm
remember when we had this interview in
in a building
and I think the janitor of the building
was following us for real for real like
we went up the elevator and a guy went
in our elevator real quick and then we
went to the wrong
the wrong floor
and he wanted to get out so we got out
it was like oh that's the wrong floor so
we got back in and was like were you for
the reason why I got upset about that
because the [ __ ] was looking
dustier than us
and it's just a pity
like you
you gonna do something to your
[ __ ] building when you look like
a whole ass trash Panda
rummaging to rubbish and you're looking
at me wrong dude you looking Dusty as
[ __ ] right now yeah that's the only
reason when I got upset but yeah you
can't have always a reaction you know
it's one of those things that I'm not
not happy to admit but it is true it's
like I do have to like and this is also
something I learned from my mom from a
young age but she was always very
cognizant of how people viewed us as
immigrants you get what I'm saying
that's why your parents always they tell
you don't don't don't don't
don't laugh too it's too loud don't
speak too loud don't speak too loud
don't take space don't don't do this
don't do that don't don't don't when I
because less attention you draw to
yourself when I bleach my hair my dad
was like yo you black yeah you you
already have attention on you don't
drive a red car don't drive a red car
all my cars all my cars what colors they
were black black black black black black
black black black black black black
black black black black black black
black all the bikes I own black
when I get a vehicle that's not black I
get it wrapped what color black yeah so
it made me so so conscious of that so
even my behavior in professional
settings and all these things I had to
go like the extra mile above and beyond
to sound a certain way to move a certain
way because it's just like it was an
issue nowadays it's not nearly as bad as
it used to be before it was way worse
before it was way worse I'll talk about
getting followed all the time cops just
running up on you like I got so
accustomed to it at some point like I I
knew when undercover cops were like
around it was really creepy I tell my
friend that's another cup sandwich
pulled off boom it was like very I I
remember even when I was living in Los
Angeles I used to get pulled over on my
[ __ ] bicycle binder cover cops you
know what I'm saying like and I knew it
was coming too on a bicycle now I'm not
even getting a ticket they just want
nowadays not as bad so I'm not even
gonna pretend like it was what it's used
to no it was bad it was worse back then
it was it was man
and you get used so much the distance
you ask questions they don't even know
how to answer like yeah you being stupid
right now yeah yeah you're being stupid
right it's exhausting it's exhausting I
match the description of someone what's
the description
you have it on picture where's the
picture so you're trying to match with
someone you're trying to match me with
someone that you don't even have a
picture of
if you don't get the [ __ ] out of here
boy this [ __ ] a lot of times but
it's [ __ ] you know you know when
that's when you do something wrong when
you do something wrong I understand when
you do something when you do nothing bro
when you do nothing you get accused that
[ __ ] will piss you the [ __ ] off but I
don't want to stand this topic for too
long let us know what you guys think in
the comments below do you guys feel any
type of way about what the lady did or
some of the stuff we said we want to
hear from you